esta vez tenemos tres fracciones
distintas menos tres cuartos
- siete sextos menos tres sextos y lo
primero que llama mi atención es ver que
estas dos fracciones menos siete sextos
menos tres sextos tienen el mismo
denominador 6 así es que primero me
encargaré de esta parte y después se lo
sumaré a esto
tenemos 7 sextos menos 3 sextos
significa que tenemos
menos siete menos tres sobre seis
bajaremos entonces este tres cuartos al
cual le sumaremos lo que sea que nos
resulte de aquí
esto será 7 menos 7 menos 3 es igual a
menos 10 sobre 6 y entonces tenemos
también este menos tres cuartos al cual
le sumaremos esto ahora para que podamos
hacer nuestra suma ocupamos tener un
denominador común que en este caso
pensemos cuál será el número más pequeño
por el cual podamos dividir entre 4 y
entre 6 de tal manera que tengamos
números enteros una forma con la que
podemos obtener esto es pensando los
factores primos
que si analizamos el 4 lo tenemos como
todos por 2 y el 6 como dos por tres
así es que si tenemos 2 por 2 4 por 3 12
12 será nuestro denominador o nuestro
mínimo común múltiplo vamos a hacer un
poco de espacio y entonces eso
significará que aquí tendremos algo
sobre 12 de la misma manera que aquí
tendremos algo sobre 12 hemos llegado a
este 12 en el denominador multiplicando
4 por 3 4 por 3 es igual a 12
entonces multiplicaremos el numerador
por esos mismos 3 3 por 3 es igual a 9 y
tiene un signo negativo ahora lo que
haremos aquí es
6 para llegar a 12 lo multiplicamos por
2 entonces el 10 que tenemos arriba lo
multiplicaremos por 2 para tener una
fracción equivalente tendremos entonces
menos 10 por 2 es igual a menos 20
así es que tenemos este par de
fracciones se ha simplificado a menos 9
doceavos menos 2012 a 2 realmente esta
es una suma vamos a hacer esta operación
tenemos menos nueve menos 20 es igual a
negativo sobre 12
y tenemos una respuesta para que
nosotros sepamos si esta es nuestra
respuesta adecuada ocupamos hacer lo
siguiente ya tenemos una fracción sin
embargo veamos si esta fracción se puede
simplificar y lleguemos a una versión
mucho más simplificada entre qué número
podemos dividir tanto el 29 como el 12
para tener una fracción simplificada el
29 es un número primo por lo que sólo se
puede dividir entre 1 y 29 mientras que
el 12 bueno no se puede dividir entre 29
por lo que nuestra respuesta
simplificada será 29 doceavos
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo